two different operations to lengthen it
or to Gerson it girth in it growth in it
you do both at the same time I think
it's highly not recommended but
someone's gonna die in there you gotta
choose why doctors while she's going
what did she just say
look it's like a groundbreaking Jesus
Christ then he puts the formula on glass
and he's like it works bigger and
girthier Y equals MX plus Kirk
he's like in a worm far away and he's
like they're gonna go through he's like
they don't it's gonna blow up this
thing's gonna blow up
there's a guy who turns around and goes
you know that's never gonna work
the jaded veteran he's in a wheelchair
though I tried yeah his legs are gone
bro
that's never gonna make it happen he's
like at least I'm alive you should see
my wife cut to a headstone